Now that we have our
competitive analysis laid out,
we need to complete a key
part of our pitch deck,
and coincidentally,
part of your final project.
This is the value proposition.
Our value proposition is our promise
of value to our customers or investors.
Now it explains what problem
our product solves, and
what benefits we're
giving our customers.
We need a frame or value proposition so
everything we learn in this lesson
is clear, organized, and powerful.
The leading template for value
propositions in use today was written by
none other than Geoffrey Moore,
in his book Crossing the Chasm.
So let's hear from the expert himself.
>> When it comes to articulating
a value proposition,
we have a template that we use in our
practice which has got six lines and
it's proved over the years
to be pretty useful.
So the first line is for and
that's just like who you're talking to.
And we'll talk about market
segmentation, but we're going to talk to
what we call the poster child in your
segment, you're perfect target customer.
And the next line is called who.
And that specifies the state
that your target customer
would be in, in wanting your offer.
So you have for these people,
who are in this state of mind.
Then the third line, it's called
our product or our service is.
And that's where you categorize
your offer generically.
It's a little bit like,
what aisle in the supermarket would
I go to to find your product?
It's sort of that sort of
thing is in line three.
So you're not trying to
differentiate in line three,
you're just trying to say what you are.
And then that, and then the fourth
line is your primary benefit.
The thing that basically, it speaks a
lot to the state that the customer's in.
Typically if the state is a problem
state this is the answer to that
problem kind of thing.
And then the last two lines help
position you against your closest
competitor.
So unlike, and this is where you
put your closest competitor, and
what's important here is that you not
pick a competitor that's ineffective or
not valuable to the customer.
You want to pick a legitimate
alternative that this customer
should probably be thinking about.
But then what you say is unlike
this competitor, our offer, and
that's the sixth line.
And you state your primary
differentiation there.
And it's not that our offer is better.
It's typically what you normally do
with differentiation, is you say,
they are good for this and
we're good for that.